mr. president in his first interview
with a British television channel since
the maritime clash in the Strait of
Kerch the Ukrainian president told Sky
News the world needs to unite against
Russian aggression
nobody knows where tomorrow Putin
appears does it possible that Putin will
make a decision to to protect the no
stream to him that's why he won't he
make a decision to attack Baltic
countries Nordic countries there is no
red line for Putin and with this
situation this is the very strong reason
that we should be together the whole
civilized world
not only the leaders with whom I have a
very reliable partnership but the people
of UK people of Europe people of us
people of Australia Canada Japan the
people the whole civilized world would
be together and this is extremely
important for the global security mr.
poroshenko stopped short of calling this
an act of war but says his military is
ready to defend the country Russia he
claims is strangling Ukraine's ability
to pass through these waters they wanna
hit Ukraine because through hours of sea
and through our Seaport Mariupol in
berdyansk we export about 40% of our
industrial production of our export
first of all this is a chemical
production iron and steel industry just
this is another step for Emperor when
Russia organized the embargo on the by
Ukrainian Goods the switch off supply of
the natural gas this is the part of the
hybrid war that Russia wanna attack us
and what is the reason if you ask me the
reason is very simple we hate the idea
anymore to stay a colony of Russian
Empire we hate the idea to stay anymore
in the Soviet Union framework we are
European nation and we wanna return back
to the European family Ukrainian troops
have been carrying out military exercise
it's a reminder that the war in the east
against russian-backed separatists has
never ended Ukraine's leader showed me
aerial photographs which he claims shows
Russian tanks massing on the border you
see this is the tank base just 18
kilometers from our border this what
happening in September
this would happening in beginning of
October and this is what happening now
so where is this this is 18 kilometers
from my border and this is the same
warehouses with the ammunition the same
warehouses with a new multi rocket
launch system we should be prepared to
protect my country and this is the only
reason if the whole world do not trust
mr. Putin Ukrainian definitely don't
have a reason in response martial laws
been introduced for the next 30 days but
Russia accuses mr. poroshenko of using
the incidents for domestic political
reasons he's facing electoral defeat in
next year's presidential elections and
the Kremlin claims he wants to look like
a strong man I have two very bad news
for mr. Putin news number one the
Russian president never ever will decide
who will be the president in Ukraine
this decision will be made by Ukrainian
people and I'm confident and trust
Ukrainian people and point number two if
because of the martial law we cancel the
presidential election with this
situation only one person will win do
you know his name this is name mr. Putin
but Russia maintains the class was a
provocation and the Ukrainian sailors
will continue to appear in court facing
criminal charges the Strait of Kerch
though remains a flashpoint it's feared
this tiny stretch of water may still
lead to a wider Escalade
Alex Rossy Sky News Kiev